terrific actor but also very good at
doing comedy and and sketch work and
improvisation and and and I'm I'm told
that you had a unique way of coming up
with a character once that you actually
came up with a character while you were
in third I was I had a great therapist
by the way and whatever she's just
wonderful I was I was complaining and it
was um I was a voice like this and I was
explaining how I was on the bike path
and someone passed me on the right which
is dangerous yeah you know you could you
could die you getting so she said
because the path on the left on the
right and so she just laughed in my face
and said next week I'm back and with a
monologue and I did and I called her the
angry lady have you ever seen the angry
lady I where like that thing you bite
CBS that says you have a bad magnetic
race and she had an eyepatch and she
every story she told ended with her
humiliating herself and peeing in her
pants okay here's my warm urine question
yes let's not get specific I don't need
to know the temperature of the year
really hell of a trademark you know
here's my question you said you had a
great therapist that does not sound like
you told your therapist something that
was really bothering you and your
therapist said hey entertain me more
when you care and laugh at that stuff
that stuff gets healed and it goes away
when you're taking it so seriously and
you're so mad that you can barely speak
above a whisper there's a problem there
but if you can find a character and you
can find a way to laugh at it you're
healed
boom okay I just I know my side
like crossfire so when I gotta go to my
therapist next we can say my father used
to beat me with a broom handle when I
was a kid I love it next week character
do you hit E the batboy I know maybe it
would work stuff out I don't know I
think it's right father never gave me
about way with a letter a limerick